[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
five minutes
[Music]
[Music]
so what was their pick five minutes
thank you so much all right good
afternoon everyone thank you for your
patience again thank you for being here
my name is Elizabeth Espinoza Elizabeth
Li za b eth Espinosa ESPI and OSA I am
the executive director of communications
for the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department and again we want to thank
you the media media from all over the
world for being here at the station for
this briefing where we have of course
the NTSB with us now again we want to
remind you that this is an ongoing
investigation which means it is a fluid
situation and we will certainly try to
provide you with as much information as
possible at this time the outline of
what the press conference will look like
is we will start with the NTSB who was
the lead in this investigation that's a
National Transportation Safety Board
Member Jennifer Hammond II will speak to
you first she will then take your
questions and after that Los Angeles
County Sheriff Alex via Nueva will come
up here and make his remarks and he will
also make remarks in Espanola for our
media and in Spanish and also the
sheriff will take questions from you at
that point as well we also want to
mention that the LA County Fire Deputy
Chief Maroney is also here if you have
questions that are fire related in this
matter so we're gonna begin now with
NTSB board member Jennifer Hamid II
welcome him thank you again my name is
Jennifer Hammond II and I'm a board
member with the National Transportation
Safety Board with me today is member Tom
Chapman and bill English who is our
investigator in charge we call the
investigator in charge the IIC the in
the NTSB is an independent federal
agency charged by Congress with
investigating every civil aviation
accident in the United States and
significant accidents in other modes of
transportation we're here to conduct a
safety investigation and our mission is
not to just determine what happened but
why it happened and how it happened
to prevent this accident a similar
accident from ever happening again
before I go any further I want to once
again extend our deepest sympathies to
those who lost loved ones in this tragic
event I can't imagine what the families
and friends of those who perished in
this accident are going through but know
that our hearts go out to you and we you
will be on our minds over the next days
and months and years ahead this morning
we began with an organizational meeting
where we established parties to the
investigation parties to the
investigation our entities that can
provide technical expertise that will
help us in gathering factual information
to help us conduct the investigation and
the parties to the investigation are the
Federal Aviation Administration Sikorsky
Pratt & Whitney Canada Island Express
and the National air traffic controllers
Association we also established
investigative groups we take our
investigators and the parties to the
investigations to the to the
investigation and we established smaller
groups to drill down to get the factual
information that we need
the investigative groups we formed our
operations and Human Performance they
will look at the pilot the
organizational structure the company how
the company is regulated air traffic
control which will look at the history
of the flight air worthiness which will
look at the airframe instruments
wreckage seat configuration and flight
controls power plants which will look at
the engines there were two pratt &
whitney canada PT six turboshaft engines
and the power plants groups will folk
on that we also have a weather
investigator and speaking of weather we
have a request for the public we're
looking for photos of the weather in the
area of the crash if you have photos
that can help us again in the area of
the crash if you could send those photos
to witness at NTSB gov that's witness at
NTSB gov we're not just focusing on
weather here though we are treyton talk
we take a broad look at everything
around an investigation around an
accident we look at man-machine and the
environment and weather is just a small
portion of that so we would appreciate
the public's assistance if you have that
please send that and again to witness at
NTSB gov we also went on scene today our
investigators began documenting the
scene collecting evidence taking
pictures and we had drones in the air to
begin mapping the wreckage there have
been a lot of questions about the FBI
and why the FBI is here the NTSB has a
memorandum of understanding with the FBI
to help us collect evidence they are
essentially a force multiplier for the
NTSB there is no criminal portion of
this investigation so with that I really
want to thank the FBI evidence response
team for their assistance with our
investigation I also want to take a
moment to thank the Los Angeles County
Fire Department the Los Angeles County
Sheriff's Office the Los Angeles Police
Department a variety of search and
rescue groups many of which I saw hard
at work today on scene and the Las
Virgenes Water District again this is
our first full day
we're continuing continuing to gather
information I do have some factual
information on the flight path with that
I want I want to read it because I want
to make sure it is reported accurately
and so if you if you'll bear with me as
I read it its initial information shows
that the helicopter was flying under
visual flight rules or VFR from John
Wayne Airport to just southeast of
Burbank Airport around Burbank the pilot
requested to transit controlled airspace
under special visual flight rules
special VFR is an air traffic control
authorization that allows an aircraft to
proceed through controlled airspace at
less than the basic VFR minimums of a
thousand foot ceiling and three miles
visibility ATC advised the pilot there
was a delay due to traffic while
awaiting approval the helicopter circled
for 12 minutes until the special VFR was
approved by air traffic control the
helicopter transited the Burbank and Van
Nuys airspace at 1,400 feet and
proceeded south then west the pilot
requested flight following to continue
to Camarillo but Southern California
TRACON advised the pilot that they were
too low for flight following
approximately four minutes later the
pilot advised they were climbing to
avoid a cloud layer when ATC asked what
the pilot planned to do there was no
reply radar data indicates the
helicopter climbed to 2300 feet and then
began a left descending turn last radar
contact was around 9:45 a.m. and is
consistent with the accident location I
anticipate we'll have more factual
information to
err tomorrow I believe we will have a
press briefing at some point tomorrow
please monitor our Twitter feed at nd
NTSB underscore newsroom where we'll put
out the time of the press conference I
do anticipate we will be here about five
days unseen to collect perishable
evidence we're going to continue to
document the scene we are not here to
determine the cause of the accident we
will not determine that on-scene
on-scene we are here to get the
perishable evidence so with that I will
take some questions and again monitor
our Twitter feed for tomorrow at NTSB
underscore newsroom
[Music]
we're still we still need to verify that
in the question was was the was the
helicopter going too fast
that's still something we have to
analyze as part of our investigation the
question is what is flight following and
I do think that is important flight
following is radar our systems for the
flight and helps the pilot avoid traffic
it's communication between in this
situation air traffic control and the
pilot it is when when air traffic
control said they were too low it wasn't
that they were too low it was too low to
provide flight following assistance it
can be yep
did the question is did anyone else
report similar issues in this weather
that is part of our interview process
and they'll be looking into them
the question is should the pilot have
been flying in that in the fog at that
time I mean that's part of our
investigation we look at whether and
we'll have to determine that at some
point Steve hold on
the question is to describe the wreckage
scene and whether I had been to the
right bracket to the scene I did go to
the scene for several hours this morning
and departed around 12:30 12:00 12:30
the the scene itself and you asked for a
description on the scene the there is a
impact area on one of the hills and the
a piece of the tail is down the hill on
the left side of the hill the fuselage
is over on the other side of of that
hill and then the main rotor is about a
hundred yards beyond that it looks about
the debris field is about 500 to 600
feet
the question is what is what is the
debris-filled tell us about the force of
the impact
I mean we're continuing to look at that
our investigators are still on seeing
again it's just the first day but that
will help us you had a question about
the black box the question is was did we
recover a black box there wasn't a black
box and there isn't requirement to have
a black box on this so there was no CVR
no FDR there were there was an ipad
where for flight which is essentially a
flight plan whether briefings and the
pilot uses that in-flight we'll be
looking at other avionics on the
aircraft to see what information we can
gather and then we're going to be
looking for other electronics question
is was there any chance for survival
that's part of the investigation I mean
it was a pretty devastating accident
scene
the question is whether it's a normal
time to wait for wait 12 minutes for
permission to proceed and there are
times where flights are held out that'll
be part of the investigation as we look
into this go ahead
the question is given the corner is
still on site how does this impact our
investigation it doesn't we are working
alongside they will they are doing what
they need to do for recovery and we are
doing our part of the investigation for
collecting evidence and drone mapping so
they're doing their part we're doing
ours and we're all on scene correct
question is how is the area being
guarded that is something that the Los
Angeles Sheriff's Department can answer
that is something they have under
control I'm sorry is the weather
investigator NTSB the weather
investigator is we have meteorologists
on staff that's correct
what's that is there another route we'll
look at that as part of our ATC review
the altitude is 1075 with that 1080 1085
the impact crater is 1085 feet above sea
level question is whether it was all the
wreckage found in the same location was
the debris field was around you know 500
600 feet it's what with
did the helicopter land right-side up is
the question the debris field is pretty
extensive and so as I said there was one
initial impact part of the debris was
down the hill another part of the debris
was over the hill and then the main
rotor was about 100 100 feet beyond that
last question last one the question is
how confident are we that we'll find a
definitive cause we do this all the time
you know the wreckage is just a part of
an investigation there's a lot of
information that we request as part of
an investigation that's pilot records
company records information on weather
ATC communications so the wreckage
itself is only a piece of that so I'm
very confident we'll determine the cause
of the accident thank you so now we're
gonna bring up LA County Sheriff Alex VN
whoever who will make us remarks in
English and then any addresses thank you
good afternoon
as a question arose earlier we have now
we have secured the the crash site and
we expanded perimeter around the crash
site and the mountains recreation and
Conservancy Authority has issued
emergency ordinance is gonna make it a
misdemeanor for anyone to unlawfully
access the crash site unfortunately
we've had in inordinate amount of
interest in accessing the crash site by
an authorized personnel so we are now
patrolling the area on horseback
old-fashioned technology our mounted
enforcement detail is out there we also
have deputies on ATVs patrolling the
area in the perimeter because very
rugged terrain very difficult to access
and we want to make sure everyone stays
where they should be an outside of the
the first responders outside of the
people that do in the investigation and
keep everyone safe because the area is
dangerous even in dates
by the the steepness of the terrain we
have the road closures to remain in
effect so that's gonna be the off ramps
of Las Virgenes on the 101 freeway both
the northbound in this southbound
off-ramp and then in Las Virgenes Road
itself from Ogura Road to Lost Hills
Road will remain closed so only
residents they have ID will allow to
enter to enter that area itself everyone
else just please stay away and those are
restrictions the flight restrictions for
five nautical miles and a 5,000 foot
ceiling they'll still remain in effect
for the duration of this and that's what
we have going right now and I just want
to take a moment to let never remember
that we're still waiting on the coroner
to do their job to make the
identifications they were busy
recovering the remains as we speak it's
a very difficult task it's gonna take a
while so be patient and as they develop
the information they make the
announcements or the notifications the
next-of-kin then we can lawfully and
responsibly release that information to
the media so remember that this impacted
so many families and there's husbands
and lost their wives why has lost their
husbands parents lost their children and
vice versa so it's it's a it's a tough
tough day for everyone a tough day for
the entire world so bear with us while
we get through this and that's all I
have for now all I say before we go let
me before he answers questioning me
switch the Spanish here that the hurling
tener que la investigación yeah yes yeah
comenzado yellows investigadores del
NTSB yes Dan a key is done at stamp
processed and Oh el lugar is Santa Mon
evidence eeeh
they'll Aria they don't occur he'll
disaster a loss on los oficial ezel
medical forensic estan Rio Hondo Oh
tomando todos los los restos hermanos
evenin pasar el laborious Oh
investigación para determinar
identification in notification laws
family eres para todos ellos saben que
es para he recover arias restos para que
pueden hacer su sorry gloss con los
los asuntos Funeraria CSS is a process
of order our varios días e tenemos que
recordar que aqui es photos per day on a
sucess Passos padres period er Anasazi
hose a hose perdieron a sus padres s
algo muy DeLauro so y know a carro
extender my condolences a toda la
comunidad impact ah de a todos
familiarity hablando con ellos
personalmente muy Dolorosa y que ramos
KO sewon que NOS han solo's que estamos
aqui nosotros kong ages and now well we
we have we have a protocol before our
our most of our helicopter based out of
Long Beach Airport and when they're
socked in with a low visibility because
of the fog or the morning the marine
layer they just not going to take off to
this unsafe yes I am NOT going to
mention who I spoke to I'll say that we
have we have been in contact we had some
of the the victims families here we
spoke with them we offered our services
our chaplains and we made arrangements
it's to provide them all the support
that we we can offer them and we'll
leave it at that
I think they said the crater was 1085
feet initially we had an issue with
drones over the site and we had
unfortunately the paparazzi overnight we
had people trying to access the site on
foot and so we were able to basically
shoo everybody away we established a
perimeter and now we have it on
horseback and ATV and we're gonna
maintain that presence 24/7 until the
entire area is done well it's not safe
because our helicopters the ones that
are long beach that are this the patrol
helicopters they're smaller they only
seat four passengers and they do not do
instrumentation flight that you have to
do visual flight only so if it's to be
if it's less than 2,000 feet visibility
they're just not taking off that's a
determination up to the NTSB that's out
of my my league no arrests have been
made but now we have the tools to make
an arrest because this is open lands
where it occurred no we were able to
intercept them in route to the site and
we were able to get everyone away and we
established the perimeter we're
maintaining it while the coroner's
office NTSB does their job yes okay
sequin egg when they condition is
nebulosa smoochin Evelina SI los pilotos
no pueden ver masa dos mil PS ages nova
novel r SS l su Regla Canosa de si por
esto los le le copious amount of Iran in
Tehran they at the corners they're still
doing the process they started
recovering human remains last night and
they're continuing for the next several
days so that's ongoing
well it's rugged terrain and is very
steep hill and in fact they have to
bulldoze a road just to get a normal
sized vehicle to the location so it is
very difficult a lot of people have been
able to walk there or hike there the
investigators initially the fire
department their first response they
were airdrop there that kind of give you
an idea of the nature of the terrain
they're in the process of making those
identification not not our call yet and
hopefully the next few days it will have
some identifications what their flight
plan is or where it would that's up to
the NTSB
the question on the pilot experience
pilot had a commercial certificate he
was a certified flight instructor on he
had a second class medical and on the
last one which was delayed dated july
2019
he had 8200 hours of flight time it's
it's he's it's an experienced pilot so
you figure that's July he's got more
time now we would have gotten updated
information on his flight time in this
July the question is are there any
issues in his record and that is part of
what we will be looking at in the
investigation we've requested that
information
the question is was he a regular pilot
he had been working my understanding is
he and we're still trying to confirm his
time at the company but he had been my
understanding is he had been working at
the company for a number of years
was it a combination of both one is very
safe for them to fly and on top of that
we need their I say to be able to access
what's on the ground to relay
information to the ground troops so
makes them useless not being able to see
sniffing everyone
as same from nación is so varsity just
get in English we're not making any
confirmation identification of any
person that'll be up to the coroner's
office when they complete the
investigation
Oso a Sunnah frequency the radio that'll
be up to the family and the
organization's they belong dude to make
those announcements as the information
is developed sir
si si podemos interpret in intercept r e
rachel urato los content an accessory
Luke a lugar thank you so much how's
that
it's you have well-wishers looky-loos
people that are grieving heart it's a
mixture of everybody thank you thank you
so much thank you so much just to remind
you though for any further
you know briefings on our end we will
certainly ask you to monitor our Twitter
feed which is at le SD h q thank you so
much again mu second I have to roast a
turkey
through proper channels while the
president certainly enjoys the power to
do otherwise there is consequence to
that action as we have now witnessed
after all that is why we are all here
but it is another thing altogether to
claim that such conduct is clearly and
unmistakably impeachable as an abuse of
power there can be no serious question
that this president or any president
acts lawfully in requesting foreign
assistance with investigations into
possible corruption even when it might
potentially involve another politician
to argue otherwise would be to engage in
the specious contention that a
presidential candidate or for that
matter any candidate enjoys absolute
immunity from investigation during the
course of the campaign I can tell you
that's not the case from my own
experience I did so during 2000 in
investigating Hillary Clinton while she
was running for office to become a
United States Senator from New York to
which she was elected my point simply is
this this president has been impeach and
stands trial here in the Senate for
allegedly doing something indirectly
about which he was entirely permitted to
do directly that cannot form a basis as
an abuse of power article sufficient to
warrant his removal from office turning
now to the second article of impeachment
as we argued in our written trial brief
at the outset it must be noted that it's
at least a little odd for house managers
to be arguing that president trumps
somehow obstructed Congress when he
Declassified and released what is the
central piece of evidence in this case
and that's of course the transcript of
the July 25th call as well as the call
with president szalinski that preceded
it on April 21 2009 teen release of that
full call record should have been the
end of this